في مدينة ديباه المركزية التي
تعرضت لقصف شديد من الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية
منذ أسابيع، اضطرت عائلة نيري
للعيش وسط أنقاض ما كان منزلهم في السابق، وتم
إنقاذ خالد وزوجته من تحت الأنقاض
بأعجوبة، ولكنهما نجيا الآن
بلا مكان.  للذهاب، يجب على هذه العائلة أن تكتفي
بالقليل الذي تبقى لها. وقد
حذرت الأمم المتحدة من أن حوالي 70٪ من
الناس في غزة يضطرون الآن إلى شرب
المياه الملوثة، ومياه الصرف الصحي الخام التي يقال إنها
تتدفق في الشوارع في بعض
المناطق، بينما الحكومة الإسرائيلية
تقول إنها ستسمح الآن لشاحنتي وقود
بالدخول إلى غزة يوميًا لدعم أنظمة المياه والصرف
الصحي. ويقال إن القطاع بأكمله
يواجه احتمال
المجاعة الفوري وفقًا لبرنامج الأغذية العالمي التابع للأمم المتحدة،
ولا توجد كهرباء ولا
مياه جارية هنا، كما أن القطاع بأكمله يواجه خطر المجاعة.  انخفاض درجات الحرارة
ليس لدى هذه العائلة خيار سوى
النوم في البرد
تقول ابنة خالد إنها وضعت غطاء
من النايلون لحمايتها من الرياح
والمطر ليلاً، وقد تركت هذه البطانيات جميع أفراد
الأسرة لتدفئتهم
وباقي ممتلكاتهم المتشابكة
ودفنوا وسط الأنقاض السوداء المحروقة
عبر شمال ووسط غزة، مشاهد
الدمار هي كل ما بقي من
المدنيين الذين طلب منهم الإخلاء جنوبًا،
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه
يستهدف حماس ويسمح
بممرات الإخلاء،
لكن حتى في الجنوب لا يوجد مفر
من هذا الجدار العقابي.  الآثار التي
ترونها هنا هي منازل في مدينة
خان يونس الجنوبية وسط الدمار
أفراد عائلة أبو زناد يقفون
عاجزين وأحبائهم ما زالوا مدفونين تحت
الأنقاض
على أرض مستشفى ناسا جنوب غزة،
وتقام صلاة جنازة أخرى
مغلقة برسالة سلام  وسط
خسارة لا يمكن تصورها مع تزايد المخاوف من
توغل بري موسع يقال إنه يستهدف
حماس في الجنوب بعد أن أسقطت القوات الإسرائيلية
منشورات بالقرب من كان يونس تحذر
الناس من الانتقال إلى ملاجئ معروفة يوم
الخميس، ولكن مع نزوح حوالي 1.5 مليون
شخص بالفعل،
لا يوجد مكان آمن يلجأون إليه.  ومع مرور كل ساعة، لا يكون هناك
سوى المزيد من عدم اليقين
والمزيد من
المأساة، حيث يهرع الجرحى عبر
قاعات المستشفى المزدحمة، والأطفال الذين تعرضوا للضرب والدماء
يتقاسمون أي مساحات متبقية في
غرفة الطوارئ المليئة بالذعر، ولكن بينما
يتسابق الأطباء في الجنوب لإنقاذ
الناجين الجرحى في الشمال  تمامًا
مثلما يكافح خالد وعائلته
للتأقلم مع هذا الواقع الممزق الآن،
يقول خالد إن الجيران اعتقدوا أنه
مات عندما أخرجوه من
تحت الأنقاض، ويقول الآن إنه يتمنى لو قُتل أيضًا
في الغارة الجوية على غزة،
الموتى فقط هم  بسلام NE بشير سي إن إن
في
القدس